moi au raymond roger roger oui moi
j'essaie toujours de faire 150 euros les
cours semblent parler de panneaux mais
en tout au tout en tout avec le loyer
avec le voyez j'en serais moi j'ai un
crédit à 800 euros après j'ai des
courses ça peut faire 400 euros de
courses par mois à taper des millions à
près de 1000 euros par mois rappelé au
moins un peu moi un peu moins puisque
j'arrive avec mon salaire de livreurs
donc non pour moi je sais pas gatouillat
internet faut tout regarder sur adil
loyer qu'on partage à deux les courses
avec trois enfants un petit délice
mousse et si vous voyez ce que vous
voulez pour se soigner avec des menus
ont fait pas réfléchir à ce qu'on va
manger le soir et donc du coup on fait
des merveilles pour faire des économies
bah en fait aussi attention si vous
faites des menus avec du caviar c'est
sûr que tu vois pas très pratique mais
c'est vrai je trouve que c'est mais vous
dites qu'il faut acheter au détail on a
besoin d'aller prendre un juste un
yaourt ou de yahoo
il ya la possibil
là il ya ça dépend du code-barres y en a
qui sont vendus en pack nouveau faux-pas
faut pas trop jouer avec ça mais en
théorie le droit de la consommation vous
autorise à prendre de yaourt sur un
paquet de six d'accord lorsque vous
allez arriver à la caisse ça va être un
peu moins agréable le moment oui vous au
guillaume genton
j'ai fait tout ça pour
ça
que tu transpires voulez la vérité oui
beaucoup trop d'argent une fourchette
avant plusieurs dizaines de milliers
la vérité ou non minarets en plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros par mois
mais non mais quand elles me disent on
devrait dire la vérité
dix mille euros oui mais tentant
d'entrer de quoi autant d'entrées pour
dépenser autrement oui il est prêt à
féliciter
qui travaille dans un bar à tapas
voilà plus de quinze bien oui voilà plus
de vingt mille
oui quoi nous tombâmes termine je vais
arrêter et puisque si rim mais vous
dépensez alors
sur le front du chômage des dépenses
pour vous vous faites le bateau c'est
que juillet-août
ils sont pas que le pack soleil de ta
gueule
est-ce que les jets sont moins chers
c'est une vraie question
mais s'il vous plaît on était sur un
avis
non mais est donc et donc vous êtes donc
c'est tout
mes cassettes castaldi vous vous étiez
tout le temps a découvert il a une
anecdote castaldi et l époque où les
banques et il voulait c'est d'y
descendre décembre décembre 17 décembre
et moi il m'a vraiment lésés descendre
très très très rare et à très bas hasebe
ça sert à ça m'a coûté ça a été tu as
participé à ma chute jusqu'à 2008
soyez oui il y avait 2000 4 2 millions
8,2 millions huit cent mille euros de
dérouler sa dépendance qui à côté j'ai
en fait il avait pris à l'école j'ai
pris mon appartement un garantie ah oui
j'oubliais on dit maintenant faut
rembourser mais oui comment je fais on
va vous prendre votre appart à brécey a
commencé comme ça non remboursés oui oui
bah oui mais bon c'est la connerie